welcome to the man of Recaps this is
House of the Dragon season one welcome
back to Westeros for the Game of Thrones
prequel Series where 200 years earlier
so multiple Generations back by the time
of Game of Thrones Dragons Were thought
to be extinct but right now we're in the
dragon Golden Age the targaryens have
like a dozen of them one of the Dragon
Riders is our main character princess
raniera Targaryen who's a cool willful
young girl a lot like Daenerys her
father is the king of vaserus Targaryen
and right now it's a time of peace and
prosperity everything's chill except
there's some concerns about the line of
succession because he has no Sons Ranier
is his only child there's precedent
right now to skip over female heirs and
go to the next male one which would be
the king's brother Damon Targaryen now
Damon is a complicated character he's
not like a bad bad guy but he does
things his own way for example they just
put him in charge of the city watch so
on night one he rounds up every criminal
in King's Landing and executes him
you're welcome guys I ended crime but
the queen is pregnant right now so in
honor of their hopefully new son they
host a grand tournament Prince Damon of
course is the favorite but it's this
random night Sir Kristen Cole who
actually wins the day more on him later
but tragically childbirth is extremely
dangerous and mother and babe both do
not survive sad times for House
Targaryen but everyone Grieves in their
own way like Damon for example goes to a
brothel and makes dead baby jokes now
remember the hand of the king is second
in command and this one's Otto Hightower
who really likes King viserys that
listens to his counsel he does not want
King Damon who will do whatever he wants
and probably fire it so Otto's all too
happy to report what Damon said so King
viserys is real mad at his brother names
him specifically not the heir and kicks
him out of the city and in a grand
public ceremony in front of all the
Lords of the realm names his daughter
raniera heir to the Iron Throne now
Damon kind of ignores this he's still
acting like he's going to be king
sovereignera has to fly in on Dragon
back to put her uncle in his place now
Damon has no problem killing people but
he doesn't want to fight his niece in
fact he really likes his niece so it's
like all right fine you're the heir now
King viserys is still a relatively young
guy and it's like hey you should remarry
to make more backup targaryens the best
marriage proposal comes from his master
of ships Corliss Valerian the sea snake
in fact he's married to the king's
cousin Randy Targaryen the female Heir
that was passed over in favor of viserys
so marrying their daughter is a little
incestual but for the targaryens that's
a good thing keep the bloodline strong
only problem is their daughter is still
way too young to get married in medieval
politics you gotta lock down that Patrol
Bowl early but viserys isn't feeling it
but there's another surprise candidate
Allison tightower daughter of hand of
the king Auto Hightower and incidentally
ranier's best friend her dad is like hey
the king is real sad about his wife's
death you should go comfort him gross
man but Allison's a dutiful daughter she
starts helping the king build his model
City and these two strike up a
friendship and so it's a two-year time
Jump as the King married Allison and
instantly had a son aegon everyone
assumes he is now the heir which is
awkward for Ranier but her dad's like
now girl you're my Heir I'm sticking to
it now what does Damon think of this
well he's been at war in the stepstones
fighting a pirate called the crabbeater
and he gets an epic action sequence
where he basically solos the entire crab
feeder Army now he comes home to King's
Landing with a haircut and an apology so
his brother instantly forgives him happy
Targaryen family again and turanera he's
the cool Uncle who sneaks her out of the
castle for a night on the town but their
pub crawl ends in a brothel uncle where
are you taking me and it wouldn't be
Game of Thrones without a little bit of
incest but for targaryens it's not weird
it's normal and they're both feeling it
so more power to you but for one reason
or another Damon decides not to go
through with it leaves her near I
hanging so when she gets home she's all
hot and bothered makes a move on her
bodyguard sir Kristen Cole yes Kristin
Cole who won the tournament trinera
named him to the King's Guard because
he's the best fighter and the hottest
now banging your bodyguard is against
the rules but these two are feeling it
so they get it on but the city of King's
Landing is full of spies that report to
the hand Otto Hightower and he would
much prefer his grandson to be King
instead of raniera so he's happy to stir
the pot again your daughter and brother
were caught in a brothel together and so
after one day of Brothers being friends
again viserys has to re-banish him now
he sends Allison to talk to renera like
yo girl did you bone your uncle renira
denies like yeah we went into the
brothel together but not together I
swear I did not bone my uncle which is
of course technically the truth but it's
a pretty big lie of a mission because
she almost did and She Bangs her Kristen
later that night but even if they didn't
do it just the rumor would ruin her
because they still have that archaic
moral system where girls having sex
before marriage spoils them but Ranier
is like yo dad check your sources
where'd this rumor come from and the
King's like you know what you're right
Otto man no hard feelings but you're
gonna be biased towards your grandson I
gotta fire you as hand of the king
Allison's real sad to see her father go
like why would my friend raniera get you
fired but her dad's like yo raniera is
not your friend anymore she's a rival
for the throne and when you play the
game of thrones you win or you die now
to quash any rumors it's time renera
gets married and they go back to the
valerians their son Lenor is about
Rainier's age and these two get along
but she's like yo cuz I know you're gay
that's fine this is a political marriage
we can love whoever we want so Lenor
gets to keep his secret boyfriend while
renira keeps her secret boyfriend
Kristen Cole you're okay with being my
secret lover right but Kristen Cole is
not okay with that he's got that archaic
moral system and now feels like he's a
terrible person but now it's time for a
Game of Thrones wedding which you know
never ends well the first drama is when
Queen Alison shows up late to upstage
renira with the grand entrance in a
bright green dress and maybe it's a
coincidence but green is the color the
high tower is like the flame when they
call the Banners To War yes tragically
she's taken her father's advice to heart
and is now real mad at her former friend
ranera and she's been influenced by
another schemer Laris strong son of the
new hand of the king and he's happy to
Spill the tea about raniera drinking the
morning after tea Allison investigates
and Kristen Cole feeling guilty
confesses instantly and Allison feels
it's wildly unfair that Ranier gets to
do whatever she wants while she's been
dutifully banging her gross Old King now
the wedding gets worse when lane or
secret boyfriend ghost Mr Kristen like
hey guess we're both Royal paramours but
this just makes her Kristen mad and no
he beats this guy to death for no good
reason dudes got serious anger
management issues now boom 10-year time
Jump we've got grown-up actors playing
the characters it's a joyous day as
raniera gives birth to her third son but
looking at their kids they don't much
look like Lenor they look a lot like new
commander of the city watch Harwin
strong yes she and Lane ore have their
happy open marriage and she and Harwin
strong have a happy secret family but
one person's not happy Queen Allison
who's apparently dedicated the last
decade to Mean Girls ingranera but King
viserys is happy to meet his new
grandson and oh dude you're not that old
what's wrong with you yeah unfortunately
the King has some bad disease and the
only thing that slows it down is cutting
off parts of your body Allison tries to
tell her husband that we're near his
kids aren't Lane org but he doesn't want
to hear it because of course if it were
true he'd have to execute the whole lot
and so for now there's a bunch of
Targaryen princes growing up together
learning important Targaryen things like
How to Train Your Dragon sir Kristen
Cole is the boy's swords Coach and he's
now BFFs with Queen Allison because
they're both nursing their grudges
against raniera so he hugely favors
Allison's kids Harwin Strong's gotta
bust in to protect him and Sir Kristen
finally says it out loud wow you protect
those boys as if you're their father so
boom marwin clocks that douche but
unfortunately that brings a lot of
unwanted attention on their situation
it's best if Harwin leaves town now
harwin's dad is like look with all these
rumors it's best if I resign his hand to
the king but viserys is like hey they're
just rumors resignation deny and this
rubs Alice into the wrong way she has
dinner with her new gossip buddy lyrics
wrong she thinks it's unfair that he
fired her dad for the same thing having
Royal grandsons she's like I wish my dad
was back and layers is like well Queen
your wish is Mac a man so it's his dad
drives Harwin home to their Castle
Harren Hall which is said to be cursed
and maybe it is because that night his
father and brother die in a fire he's
like oh no what a tragedy it's like bro
did you just murder your family he's
like did I over the years he continues
to be Allison's unofficial spymaster and
their relationship evolves from friendly
gossip over dinner to I'll give you
information in exchange for looking at
your feet now what has Damon been up to
well remember he's technically married
but now he's single again after her
unfortunate riding accident so now he
goes after none other than his brother's
almost fiance Elena Valerian and she can
handle his stuff she's a dragon rider
too these two have a happy thing but
tragically childbirth strikes again and
Lena goes out in a blaze of glory
Targaryen style dracarises herself so at
the funeral it's a big Targaryen Family
Reunion where Damon and raniera are both
grieving the losses of their loved ones
and like Will Ferrell says in wedding
crash sure's grief is Nature's Most
Powerful aphrodisiac cause ten years
after their youthful almost fleeing
these two finally get it on elsewhere on
the beach another Targaryen is up to no
good this is Alison's Second Son Eamon
Targaryen and he's got a chip on his
shoulder because he's been bullied by
the other princes for being the only one
without a dragon but with his aunt's
death he figures her dragon is up for
grabs to the first person to claim it
and her dragons are real old model it's
vegar one of the original Three and an
absolute unit but aemond with balls of
steel like yo girl I'm gonna ride ya yip
yip and oh it's Dragon flight time oh
this kid's a maniac and dragon's bond
with the first person who rides him so
eamonn's got a dragon now Elena's
daughters are real mad that he scooped
their mom's Dragon but he's like hey you
snooze you lose losers and so it turns
into a kid's cousin fight which is a fun
time until someone loses an eye their
respective Mama bears didn't like each
other anyway and now Allison's real
pissed grabs the knife goes to cut out
one of their eyes after this it's like
yo screw Allison and her kids you and me
we're the real targaryens it's like you
know what if we were married people
wouldn't challenge my rule for being a
woman because you know you'd be King
next to me Damon's 100 in but he's like
yo you're still technically married
there's no divorce in Westeros Leonor is
gonna have to die so Damon Targaryen
puts back on his murder hoodie he makes
a deal with Leonard's current boyfriend
these two start fighting and when the
guards get there oh lane or has been
pushed into the fire I knew Damon was
kind of a bad guy but raniera I expected
better from you but wait what's this
who's that throwing the Escape boat it
is Lenor Valerian yes they faked his
death staged it so these two got to go
live a quiet life which leaves Damon
into an era free to marry each other
yeah after all these years the timing
finally was right and it's a really
sweet slightly incestuous love story and
so for a quiet six years Rainier and
Damon live happily on Dragonstone but
the sea snake cordless Valerian has been
grievously wounded and his brothers like
yo or near his kids aren't lenors I
should inherit so renera comes back to
King's Landing where her father the King
was barely hanging on he can't have made
it another six years oh but he did he's
still hanging in there barely with the
King out of Commish the real rulers are
the high Towers Alice and dinner father
Otto and they can't fully say that
raniera's kids are not Lane ores but
casting the doubt is good for their
eventual plan to put Allison's kids on
the iron throne but what's this who's
busting in now it is Old King viserys
it's just an old man walking across a
room but it's an epic scene as you can
see how much he's putting into it so
with him now ruling in raniera's son's
favor this guy's got no option left but
to go all in drops a b-bomb bastards
which oh let's Damon cut his head in
half uh yeah once he said it out loud it
was slander and like he's legally
allowed to kill him I guess so with his
whole family in town Grandpa viserys
makes the effort to stay up for dinner
where they're celebrating a double
betrothal they're Brady bunching it to
both Rainier's Sons to both Damon's
daughters and at this point the
Targaryen and Valerian family trees have
become a circle anyway for the old
King's sake everyone squashes the beef
for the night and it's a nice happy
Targaryen family dinner until grandpa
goes to bed because the Family Feud is
passed down to the new generation these
Sons don't get along and it's the
younger brother Eamon who sets things
off puberty hit this guy like a truck
he's grown up into an epic fighter and
looks real cool in his badass eye patch
he makes a speech complimenting his
nephews which is a nice gesture until he
calls them a strong of course the
surname of their real father it sets off
a whole fight again Damon's like yo
you're just a cheap knockoff of me but
eamon's like oh no I'm the upgrade a
short time later the day finally comes
when Old King viserys dies his dutiful
wife Allison was with him at the end
where he was rambling incoherently but
did say aegon should be king he was
talking about his ancestor aegon the
Conqueror but that's what you get for
naming all the kids aegons and now she's
like hey it was his dying wish that my
son aegon becomes king and the rest of
the small council is like well that's
convenient because we were gonna do it
anyway except this one guy who's like
well that seems very suspicious he
always was adamant that renira be his
Heir so Kristen Cole comes up like sit
down old man and oh he sat him down a
little too hard he killed this guy yeah
he's a repeat offender now it's like bro
I gotta take your gun and badge but it's
actually the Lord commander of the
King's Guard who takes off his white
cloak like yo y'all clearly up to some
shady stuff I want no part of it so who
is this aegon is he at least a good guy
that'll be a good King well not really
at his best he's kind of a douchey party
boy and that is worst he likes sexually
assaulting Castle servants and going to
underground children fighting rings so
they round up all the Lords like hey
Rainier is out aegon's in Bend the knee
or you know die one of the VIPs here is
rainey's Targaryen who's basically a
hostage but one of the Kings guard busts
in like yo I'm getting you out of here
but they don't make it very far because
all of King's Landing is being herded in
for King aegon's coronation and aegon
didn't want to be king he's like oh man
it's gonna be nothing but work but now
that the crowds are cheering for him
he's like you know maybe I do want to be
king but rainy sneaks downstairs because
this building big enough to house all
these people is the dragon pit yeah she
busts on out of there her Dragon was
parked right under him badass Grandma
moment she flies on over to Dragonstone
with the bad news your dad's dead and
the crowned egg on immediately and this
is pretty stressful for pregnant
rhaenyra in fact oh no something's wrong
and it's a third tragic graphic
childbirth scene but this one raniera
does survive now the kingsguard who
helped rhaenys arrives incidentally
their twin brothers Eric and Eric but
this Eric is choosing rhaenyra in fact
he smuggled out to her father's crown
and so here in front of a small group of
friends and family raniera gets her
coronation finally officially Queen but
before they start warring Otto Hightower
comes to try to make peace like look
this doesn't have to get bloody if you
bend the knee to aegon or announce all
claim to the throne you and your family
can live happily inherit their other
castles and stuff and the realm isn't
plunged into Civil War Demons of the
mind they should kill Otto right now but
Rainier is like well let's give it a
thought if we're gonna do a Targaryen
Civil War the targaryens aren't the only
house involved Stark Tully Lannister
Baratheon names you know from Game of
Thrones which sides would they fight on
gets one strong Ally right away because
Corliss Valerian the sea snake survived
his mortal wounds at this point in
history they're one of the strongest
houses in Westeros and definitely have
the most powerful navy but maybe even
more important than other allies is the
fact that this side has more dragons and
her nearest Sons Jace and Luke are like
yo instead of letters let us go as
envoys flying on our dragons to remind
everyone you know we targaryens the
younger one Luke they give the shorter
flight to Storm's end the seat of house
Baratheon he flies in on his Dragon
super impressive unless there's another
bigger dragon already parked here yes
Eamonn beats him here fully decked out
like an anime villain this Lord
baratheon's like yeah kid you're not
really impressive I already decided
decide with Team Green so Luke's going
home empty-handed but eamon's not
letting him off that easy he really
doesn't like Luke because he's the one
who cut his eye in fact he pulls his eye
patch off to show oh he's got like a
blue put a sapphire in there so it looks
like no I'm out of here he starts flying
off through the storm but what's this
massive Shadow all Eamon followed him
here on his mom monster Dragon yeah
aimand is an absolute mad lad war is not
even officially declared yet but he's
ready to get it going Luke's little
dragon manages to blast this one with
some fire but now Veigar is real mad
flying after him out of control and as
Luke flies above the storm seems like he
made it to safety but oh the big truck
can eats him Eamon didn't mean for this
to happen it seems like he was just
trying to give him a scare but uh now he
knows he done messed up because when
Rainer gets the news her son's been
murdered any hope of peace is out the
window and that's where season one comes
to an end
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]